equation we're gonna be working with is
this one here x over a plus y over b
equals 1 and basically the way that this
works is that a is our x-intercept and b
is our y-intercept now I want to explain
something really quick say for example
when you find the x and y intercept of a
equation of a line that's in this form
let's say the standard form like this
what we do is we set X to 0 to find the
y intercept and we set Y to 0 to find
the x intercept so for example if I put
0 and for X anything times 0 is 0 and if
I divide by negative 2 you can see Y is
negative 6 right and so that's going to
be where it crosses the y axis if we set
Y to 0 anything times 0 is 0 so that
cancels out this term and if we divide
by 3 you can see the x intercept is 4
right once we have those two points we
can easily graph our line right same
thing over here you can see that if we
put in 0 for X okay 0 divided by a is
just going to be 0 and so you can see
that we're left with Y over B equals 1
by multiplying both sides of the
equation by B right we're going to find
out what our y-intercept is also
conversely if we set Y to 0 that's going
to cancel this term out because 0 over B
is 0 and then by multiplying both sides
by a we're getting x equals a and again
remember is our x-intercept so that's
why it works now we're gonna look at a
couple examples now so the first one see
how it says graph x over 2 plus y over
negative 3 equals 1 so what we're gonna
do is we're gonna say okay our
x-intercept is 2 and our y-intercept is
negative 3 now remember this equation
always has to be equal to 1 if it was
equal to 2 you can divide everything by
2 but you want to set this equal to 1
and the reason that this works is again
I'm just going to show you if you
substitute in 0 for X right
just to show you why it works so 0 over
2 is 0 if I multiply both sides by
negative 3
you're gonna see that Y is equal to
negative 3 there's our y-intercept if we
set Y to 0 right 0 over negative 3 is 0
and by multiplying both sides by 2 you
can see that our x intercept is 2 but
this is just a shortcut if you recognize
that the denominator the number
the X is the x-intercept the number
underneath the y is a y-intercept once
you have those two lines you can just
draw those two points you can draw a
line through it right okay so number two
now we're working backwards we're saying
right the double intercept equation of
the line okay they're giving us the
graph notice that our y intercept is two
okay so we have Y over to our x
intercept is one two three or four
negative five so we have x over negative
5 and then equals one now if you wanted
to you could you know rewrite this a
little bit you could say Y over two
minus x over five that's another way to
do it but basically you can see
whatever's underneath the X is the
x-intercept and whatever is underneath
the Y is the y-intercept and